[Music]
blazing Vehicles satellite
yeah we woke up every morning to a news
report that was a bombing or a shooting
petrol bomb attacks on shops have been
condemned as senseless acts of violence
there was such an appetite and such a
want for people in Northern Ireland to
say there's going to be no more
25 years ago a historic deal brought
peace to Northern Ireland saving
thousands of lives
today I hope that the burden of History
can at long last start to be lifted from
our shoulders
I could still see the document in my
head when we're speaking you could feel
weight collectively lifting from society
but a generation later how well is the
Good Friday agreement still working
peace agreement is not a fairy story you
don't get to live happily ever after
the security service MI5 today raised
the terror threat in Northern Ireland to
severe
there is this glorification
of violence of the violence of the past
it's younger people who have decided to
take on that trauma for themselves and
decided that's our work
what needs to be done to preserve the
hard one piece
the best way to keep the pace is to make
sure that people have a job that they
have something that they're contributing
to that's bigger than them
and does the price of Peace have to be
bad government
there has been this lurching instability
storm it is up then it's down for a
population that has grown up in peace
they want something better and they are
the people who are increasingly pushing
for change
[Music]
Belfast Titanic quarter a tech and
tourism hub
Blockbuster fantasy Drama Game of
Thrones was shot here
and attractions like the Titanic Center
welcome hundreds of thousands of people
every year
none of this would have been possible
without the Good Friday agreement
it was a piece of high politics but
actually it has transformed Northern
Irish Society it has meant that for
instance the architecture is different
in Belfast there are lots of glass
buildings something which would have
been Madness during the troubles because
bombs were going off
there's more inward investment there are
better jobs this has had a practical
impact on people's lives in ways that
lots of people in Northern Ireland don't
necessarily think about
so how did the Good Friday agreement
achieve this transformation
well to understand that you need to go
back to 1921.
[Music]
when the Border was drawn by the British
it gave most of Ireland Independence but
meant six Northern counties remained
part of the UK
most people here were Protestants who
supported the Union
and the system was designed to work in
their favor
the police were 90 percent Protestant
as were most judges
and the government was majority rule
meaning unionists would always be in
control
in the 1960s inspired by the American
Civil Rights Movement some Catholics
began demanding change and the violence
they met from loyalists intent on
keeping Northern Ireland under unionist
control the police and the British army
helped spark the 30 years of conflict
known as the troubles
[Music]
the entirety of his existence in
Northern Ireland the Catholics had never
been allowed any power so the point of
the agreement the Friday agreement was
to have power sharing so the minority
Catholics could participate in
government
the agreement promised to reform the
police overhaul the justice system
and create a totally new form of
government which meant no Community
could dominate another
it was an unprecedented achievement
Jonathan Powell was the British
government's Chief negotiator
we were negotiating for three days a
night which were at sleep essentially
people were getting slightly hysterical
the truth was we could have lost it at
any period it took another nine years of
negotiation to get the institutions up
and running and get the agreement fully
implemented
in the decade after 1998 paramilitaries
decommissioned their weapons
and the deal protected the delicate
issue of identity
people here could now choose to be
British Irish or both
and it was written into the agreement
that Northern Ireland's place in the UK
would only change if the majority of
people here wanted it to
the troubles had been going on for so
long they appeared intractable something
that just was always going to be a
problem and was insoluble and the Good
Friday agreement transformed that
the impact was remarkable at the height
of the troubles over 200 people were
being killed every year
but it is now closer to 20.
The Good Friday the Belfast agreement is
a symbol of peace still around the world
have we finished it absolutely not but
in terms of large-scale violence in
terms of those images the fact has not
people being murdered every day then
that's a huge success
but there was one event The Architects
of the agreement could not have
predicted
[Applause]
when the UK voted to leave the EU in
2016 the status of Northern Ireland
became fiercely contentious
to avoid a hard border within Ireland
prime minister Boris Johnson proposed a
trade Border in the Irish sea this
angered unionists who saw it as a
barrier between Northern Ireland and the
rest of the UK
it did add the polarization here because
a large part of the unionist community
voted to leave a large part of the
Nationalist Community voted to remain
and and Northern Ireland
um it's 56 percent of people voted for
Indiana so it was a sense of a loss of
identity it was being taken off people
and I suspected it will continue to be
hard to disentangle that vote from the
future prospects of this place
like this
what Boris Johnson really individually
managed to do was get the issue of
identity back into politics which is
extremely dangerous in Northern Ireland
this tensor atmosphere has made it
harder to heal the Grievances of the
past
and some believe the nature of the Good
Friday agreement itself means it's
impossible to move on
we're just going up here to my are we
Homestead and negani and Rural County
Down
samihinen was just 12
years father was killed by the Irish
Republican Army the IRA in 1985.
he was alone with him in their remote
Farmhouse at the time
alone gunman had been hiding behind a
wall shot Mr Heenan once in the head
so I just followed the trail of blood
around the side of the barn
along here
and as I come around the corner
my father was lying dead at this point
and I just stood over him and I I just
looked and I started a sub and cry
because I did not know what else to do
all I could do then was run down the
state and down half a mile down the road
to a neighbor's house to raise the alarm
no one was ever tried for the murder of
Sammy's father
and under the terms of the agreement if
anyone were to be convicted they would
only serve two years
that was the earthquake for victims and
I feel that we have been suffering the
aftershocks ever since
the agreement also meant that
paramilitary prisoners were released
the man coming through the turnstile at
the maze is Bernard mcginn Ira sniper
and bomb maker
even those serving life sentences for
attacks during the troubles
for Sami this felt like an insult to his
father's memory to think victims have
felt uh let down and very much betrayed
as a consequence
and he believes this has led some of the
Next Generation to romanticize the
conflict
we're supposed to be in a year of
inclusivity and respect between her two
Traditions but sadly today as many young
people have a very glorified narrative
around the Troubles of our past
sectarian violence remains a problem
here the UK recently upgraded the threat
level in Northern Ireland because of
ongoing attacks including the shooting
of policeman John Caldwell wearing masks
and armed with a gun they fired several
shots at him in front of his son
Sami has been
up day
hey totally empathize with them young
people when I spoke to him because I
could feel the pain and it brought me
back when I was a 12 year old boy
but this is very different from the
violence of the 1980s
violence that happens Now does not have
political support the reason we had to
negotiate with Shin feign in the end was
even at the height of the troubles they
had genuine support these fractional
groups we're dealing with now have no
support less than a thousand people
would even sympathize what they're doing
this is not a political issue that's a
criminal issue that needs to be dealt
with
thanks to the Good Friday agreement many
Community groups have been established
to try to tackle the problem of
sectarianism
this is peace players in North Belfast
it's really hard to actually talk to
someone from a different religion
because it's kind of frowned upon to mix
I went to a production school and coming
here I was a little bit scarred of the
integration
Society here remains deeply segregated
the children at this game go to separate
Catholic and Protestant schools like
almost all kids in Northern Ireland
in fact just nine percent of
post-primary pupils attend integrated
schools and 90 of social housing is also
segregated
there's still a lot of conflict between
the areas as a Catholic girl walking
into places like the schenckel estate is
like a really scary thing to do there's
a lot of times where you just go into an
area and someone catches winds that are
they recognize you from the other side
and still verbally or physically attack
you and it is quite like a really scary
thing
and there are other more obvious emblems
of division like the peace walls that
separate Catholic and Protestant
communities
the barrier still exists the divisions
are still there we still have peace
lines in Belfast which which are
dominating the skyline and keeping our
Traditions apart the Good Friday
agreement could create lots of
opportunities for lots of projects like
peace players to be able to happen but
also I think there's still a journey to
be traveled
hello I'm Patrick Lane I'm The Economist
Deputy digital editor if you want to
read more of our Northern Ireland
coverage why not take out a subscription
to The Economist you'll receive daily
and weekly analysis of global Affairs
you can read us online or in the app and
you can listen to our audio Edition for
the best offer click on the link
and now back to the film
this isn't just about peace walls though
the bigger problem is that since the
Good Friday agreement there hasn't been
stable government long enough to give
people paths out of violence
sorcia Eastwood represents Lagan Valley
just outside Belfast in the devolved
Stormont assembly
one thing that I would like to see more
of is actually investment in our town
jobs for our young people
apprenticeships and stuff like that that
all sounds really normal but for some
reason we can't manage to get it
together to actually enable people like
me to deliver that for my constituents
under the terms of power sharing set up
after 1998. unionists and nationalists
must govern together
and if either side walks away the
government collapses
it's a bit like Donald Trump and Joe
Biden being asked to govern together it
is a system of mutual vetoes of almost
mutually assured destruction but the
ultimate nuclear option here is for one
of those big parties to walk away
both sides have pulled the system down
in the past the assembly has collapsed
six times since 1998. leaving Northern
Ireland without a government for almost
10 years this time the Democratic
unionist party or dup has walked out
over post-brexit negotiations we are
totally opposed to the protocol as it
presently exists
we will neither accept it nor will we
work it without an assembly we can't do
anything and I can see the decisions
stacking up day after day after day and
looking at it and going this is not
right
this political paralysis has hit Public
Services
in 2020 40 of people on National Health
Service waiting lists in Northern
Ireland have been waiting over a year
for an appointment
compared with just 0.1 percent of people
in England
we have a situation where perversely
people are no longer dying because of
bullets and bombs for the most part but
they are dying because good government
is not happening
the way the assembly works is also out
of step with how people are voting
Citrus parties not defined by being
unionist or nationalist are gaining
ground
sorces party Alliance is now the third
largest in the assembly
we weren't I don't want to say burdened
but we certainly were not coming at our
politics from a main driver of a
constitutional end game
but because Alliance is neither unionist
nor nationalist their votes don't count
the rules that were drawn up in 1998
were there to protect unionism and
nationalism from bad behavior
essentially by one or the other it
didn't really Force the idea that there
might be a third tribe
when it comes to a big voot in the
assembly on something like the budget
the key thing is getting a majority of
unionists to majority of nationalists
and others don't count that's a
significant problem now where others are
are a significant force in Northern
Irish politics
Alliance are now campaigning for reform
of the system
we are simply asking that those very
modest reforms to the Good Friday
agreement could enable us to unlock so
much peace and potential prosperity and
fairness ultimately
the stakes for getting this right could
not be higher
the generation born after the troubles
are asking for more than just peace we
don't have a government system that
actually is set in stone and is working
for the future I don't think I'm really
Stan in Northern Ireland
and if reform is done right there is
remarkable potential here
I'm long-term very optimistic I think a
good Friday agreement has essentially
worked and that's not true of many peace
agreements I think Northern Ireland's
got huge possibilities economically
having this advantage of being in the
European market and the British Market
educated labor force relatively low
housing prices if we can sort out the
political instability the future of
Northern Ireland is fantastic
the challenge now is how to harness the
ambition of 1998 to create a more stable
political system one that will support
the next 25 years of peace
I'm Sam McBride and I write about
Northern Ireland for The Economist to
read more on this topic click the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]